يجلس المعلم سامح الجزار امام محله منتظرا
للزبائن الذين تراجعت اعدادهم بشده خلال
الفتره الاخيره اسعار اللحوم الحمراء قفزت
الى ارقام غير مسبوقه سامح وغيره من
الجزارين يؤكدون انهم يتضررون بسبب هذه
الاسعار التي لا دخل لهم في تحديدها الشغل
ما عادش ربع الاول
يعني الجزارين كلها كله بيعاني من قله
الشغل ومنغله
فالجزار اليومين دول يعني ماسك نفسه شويه
عشان ما يقفلش يعني سيادتك فيه الغلاء دوت
في محلات كتير قفلت اما الزبائن فقد عبروا
عن استيائهم الشديد من الزياده في الاسعار
قبل اسابيع قليله من حلول عيد الاضحى انا
معي 320 جنيه اجيب لحمه طب هو المرتب فيه
كم او المعاشي مثلا في كم 350 معدناش
قادرين نخش عليها ولا ناكلها نص كيلو اهو
علشان واحد مريض عامل له عمليه فواخذ له
النصف كيلو يعني بطلوع الروح اما اصحاب
مزارع المواشي فيؤكدون ان ارتفاع الاسعار
يعود الى الزياده الكبيره في التكلفه
وزياده اسعار مشتقات الاعلاف بسبب ازمه
الدولار يعني احنا النهارده عندنا الصويا
مثلا كان في العيد الكبير اللي فات السنه
اللي فاتت كنا بنجيبها ب 13 الف ونص
النهارده وصلت عده الاربعين الف جنيه
طبعا ده مش السعر الطبيعي بتاعها يعني ده
عدم توافرها المسؤولون الحكوميون يرجعون
ارتفاع اسعار اللحوم لعدد من الاسباب
بدايه من تعطل سلاسل الغذاء العالميه بسبب
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وصولا الى تبعات
الحرب في السودان التي عطلت عمليات
الاستيراد الحكومه قررت مضاعفه استيراد
كميات اكبر من اللحوم من عدد من الاسواق
الافريقيه والدوليه خلال المرحله المقبله
الكثير من المواطنين يتجهون لشراء اللحوم
من المنافذ التابعه للدوله باسعار اقل انا
هنا عشان السعر رخيص يعني الجزارين اللي
بره انا جايه اخد اللحمه من هنا حلوه
وارخص من الجزارين بره الفتره الماضيه
شهدت اغلاق عدد من محال الجزاره استجابه
لدعوات المقاطعه بينما ينتظر المصريون عيد
الاضحى تبقى مساله شراء اللحوم الحمراء
هاجسا للكثيرين الذين يتفاجئون بارتفاعات
شبه يوميه في اسعارها احمد عثمان العربيه
القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات